[Music]
foreign
[Music]
today is the day we can start to change
things
[Music]
make things better
and make better things
let's take on problems big or small
not yet I'm coding because they're all
worth solving
let's make Tech more helpful more open
and accessible to everyone
let's keep data safe and people safe
look after the environment and each
other
today may surprise us push us even scare
us
that's why we're here
let's take those challenges and make
something even better for tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome our CEO of Google Cloud
Thomas curion
[Music]
wow
hello Welcome to Cloud next
it's wonderful to join you from New York
to begin our Global 24-hour broadcast
with Keynotes happening live here in New
York
San Francisco
Tokyo
Bengaluru and Munich
it's my pleasure now to kick off today
by welcoming Google and alphabet CEO
Sundar pichai
thank you Thomas and thanks to everyone
joining us today wish I could be there
with you in person
I'm glad that today's even spans the
globe it's a representation of the
hybrid world we live in today
we're honored to build products that
help make this hybrid reality work even
better
from Google workspace the productivity
and collaboration apps that help three
billion users
including us get things done
to the cyber security that keeps
customers safe
and we are doing it all on the cleanest
cloud in the industry
we are seeing incredible momentum
cloud is one of our fastest growing
businesses
in Q2 we were at a 25 billion dollar
annual revenue run rate
Google Cloud helps us Advance our
mission and makes Google work better
it's what enables us to share Innovation
and investment from across Google with
companies governments and organizations
worldwide
for example we developed our Global
Network including 22 subsea cables the
bolster our infrastructure and improve
the performance of our products like
YouTube
now it's available to our customers as
well
we develop bigquery to help our search
customers
and now every company has access to the
most powerful Analytics
and because we invested for years in
threat analysis to protect everyone who
uses Google
we can help provide that same protection
to countries and companies with Google
Cloud
AI is another really important area for
Google Cloud
Google has long been an AI first company
we've made progress in some of the most
challenging areas of research including
translation computer vision and natural
language processing
these advances are powering helpful
product Innovations
from enabling people to search using
video and text simultaneously
to summarizing Long documents and
highlighting what matters
Google is also applying Cloud AI tools
to help solve our own business
challenges
I'll give you an example
Google's products are used by people
around the world who speak thousands of
different dialects and languages
it's really important we can provide
translations so everyone can access them
advances in AI are making it easier to
translate languages
including languages that aren't well
represented on the web
earlier this year we added 24 new
languages to Google Translate with
machine learning techniques that can
translate new languages without ever
seeing a direct translation
advances like these along with Google
cloud automl and the help of local
experts enable us to translate more
content than ever before
today we are launching translation Hub
to bring these capabilities to deliver
translation at scale for all of you
it is Google Cloud's AI agent that helps
companies translate content in over 135
languages
it takes full documents including images
and translates them while preserving
layouts and formatting
enabling researchers to share their
findings with global audiences
helps providers of good and services to
reach underserved markets
and governments to better serve all of
their constituents
translation Hub joins other AI Agents
from Google Cloud that apply AI to
Common business tasks
Fortune 500 company Avery Denison is
using translation hub
to translate internal Communications and
engage employees globally
this capability promotes a more
inclusive workplace with employees able
to communicate and be understood
translation is one way AI is becoming
more accessible and common
we are seeing more examples every day
during the pandemic more than half of
companies actuated their AI adoption
plans
an 86 percent said that it's becoming a
mainstream technology
we are at a Tipping Point and companies
are turning to Google Cloud to help
one of the most powerful AI applications
for organizations is the ability to
extract insights and predictions from
their data
specific to their business needs
for example Munich Ray one of the
leading reinsurance companies in the
world is collaborating with Google Cloud
to use AI to respond to natural
disasters quickly and thoroughly
our tools help them to build better
damage detection models faster and more
cost efficiently
the speeds up response time helping get
people and resources where they are
needed most
likewise Frontier development lab in
partnership with NASA Google cloud and
others has created the first 360 degree
view of the Sun
using AI they combine data from three
NASA satellites making it possible to
observe the Sun from any vantage point
this will help scientists better predict
the impact of the sun's activity on our
planet
they're also using AI to see the moon's
permanently shadowed regions
as if it were daylight an important step
in lunar exploration
finally they've built models that take
existing satellite images and transform
them to represent accurate flood
predictions
this helps planners and rescue groups
anticipate the impact of flooding to
better protect communities
looking ahead there is a new frontier of
computing that will extend this further
from augmented reality that delivers
translation and transcription directly
in your line of sight
to advances in hardware and software
that make it feel like you're in the
same room as a co-worker miles away
that's a new technology we've been
working on called project Starline
it creates a 3D model of a person
making it feel like you're sitting with
someone in the same room not at the
other end of a video call
after thousands of hours of testing in
our own offices
including demos with Enterprise Partners
we are seeing promising results
users noted the powerful ability to make
eye contact and how much more engaged
and connected they felt
today we are announcing An Early Access
program with Enterprise partners
including Salesforce and T-Mobile
starting this year we'll begin
installing Starline prototypes in select
partner offices for daily testing
it's a really exciting next step and
we're looking forward to improving this
technology together
when more people businesses and
organizations have access to the power
of Advanced Technologies amazing things
happen
that's what I see is the future of
Google cloud and fear we are grateful
for the opportunity to partner with you
on this journey
thank you all for being part of cloud
next and back to you Thomas
thank you Sundar
I'd like to thank our sponsors who've
helped make this event so successful
and who helped make our customers
successful every day especially our
luminary sponsors Accenture autos c3ai
and Deloitte
now our vision for cloud computing is to
simplify all of the technology
that organizations need
making it accessible by simplification
to every organization around the world
as software platforms that provide the
foundation for your business to digitize
and accelerate
at next you'll hear directly from
leading companies in every industry in
geography who have accelerated their
transformation with Google Cloud
in media Global live stream the Tokyo
Olympics to all of Latin America
and hosted over 55 events
in Automotive Group Renault analyzes
more than a billion data sets from their
factories every single day
saving more than a hundred million euros
in 2021 alone
in retail h m group
is improving its customer experience and
optimizing its internal supply chains
Home Depot save 30 percent by
consolidating and modernizing its
systems
and knocked our tea in France is
converting more customers with Google
quality search and recommendations
in telecommunications for instance belt
Canada is deploying 5G Network functions
in less than a week
compared to the industry standard of
over six months
in healthcare Johns Hopkins brain injury
outcomes division reduce some brain scan
review times from five hours
to just 30 seconds
we're helping financial services
companies transform too
the Chicago Mercantile Exchange or CME
Group now offers real-time Market data
for about 90 percent less cost
Prudential PLC is enhancing health and
financial inclusion across all of Africa
and Asia
ANZ bank is giving actionable insights
250 times faster Commerce Bank migrated
135 databases to run on Google Cloud
across 35 applications in less than nine
months
and minibank in Japan runs its core
banking system on Google Cloud
so as you can see Google cloud is
accelerating the transformation of
global leaders
in every industry
Google workspace
today helps 8 million customers to
transform the way they work up from 6
million just two years ago
and we continue to be the top Cloud for
technology companies
did you know that 70 percent of the top
100 unicorns in the world run on Google
Cloud
including share chat in India tocopedia
and Indonesia sift analytics in Africa
Wix in Europe and doordash in the United
States
now let's hear
directly from a few of our customers
[Music]
through AI we can reach more people
globally when and where they want it
it's the power of representation it's
giving Spanish-speaking audiences
content specifically made for them by
them
analyzing CAT scans for precise
information about a patient's lesion
used to take over 10 hours and now we
can do this in under two minutes
sustainability is absolutely critical to
all consumers with Google Cloud we can
build a much more traceable and
transparent supply chain this helps us
to stop deforestation and combat climate
change
Google Cloud helps us monitor risk
across vast amounts of data we care
deeply about the financial well-being of
Institutions corporations and
individuals
data is as a foundational need for
Twitter and that data is really
responsible for connecting people to
their interests connecting interests
amongst each other and having that
deeper conversation
[Music]
you know last year at next we talked
about the five most important questions
leading companies are asking themselves
to ensure they're transforming the
fastest
Ford is a leader in the automotive
industry and it's rapidly transforming
by adopting technology
we're very proud to have CEO Jim Farley
discuss the journey with us
thanks Thomas and hi everyone it's so
great to be with all of you
at the heart of our business at Ford is
a commitment to meet the evolving needs
of our customers now that is a lot of
corporate speak but I want to spend time
with you today to bring to life our
transformation
technology in particular digital
capability to connect a car shipping
software to cars allows us to deliver
and develop a customer relationship in
ways we've never been able to do in 119
years so this is a really big deal for
us at Ford and for me the real
revolution in Auto is digital and Ford
intends to lead that Revolution we're
turning our vehicles into generators of
data that will receive continuous
updates we can ship software directly to
the car delivering a credible value for
our customers
now we're just approaching 5 million
software updates we're leveraging that
data in new ways like telematics for our
commercial customers in Ford Pro we see
our vehicles being able to do
preventable diagnosis themselves for
service we're investing in a whole new
generation of talent coders software
Engineers from so many tech companies
want to join forward because they know
we're going to ship some great software
and some Grace products and Thomas I'm
sorry some of those are coming from
Google but we're really excited about
all the work we're actually doing with
Google who is a fundamental change agent
for this incredible change to Ford and
our customers or supercharging our use
of AI and ml to drive Innovation across
our company we doubled our number of AI
powered Solutions last year by putting
Advanced Ai and ml capabilities in the
hands of our employees not just our data
scientists these Advanced software tools
make EV charging easier our part
shipment more efficient they even help
us race better on the weekends we're
using Google data Cloud to power
operational data and analytics to
improve our manufacturing operations
efficiency and quality I hear this all
the time when I go to our plants we're
glad to be on this journey with a great
Innovative partner like Google and
Google Cloud thank you for having me
foreign
thank you Jim we couldn't be happier to
be strategic partners with Ford
the data is at the heart of digital
transformation
data is being generated at far greater
rates by everything from infrastructure
to Consumer apps
everyone wants to access it
instantaneously
but it's often trapped in different
silos and tools
Google's open data Cloud enables you to
Aggregate and understand
all your data
from all your sources
in All Storage formats
from all Cloud providers
and enabling all styles of access
Google's data cloud and bigquery make it
easy for organizations to combine all
their structured data from operational
databases and software as a service
applications like workday servicenow
Adobe sap and others
with unstructured data and
semi-structured data such as log files
did you know that over 90 percent of
Google data Cloud customers also access
and analyze data from other clouds using
Google's data cloud
bigquery Omni allows you to analyze data
stored in AWS Azure and others without
needing to actually move the data saving
egress fees
from bigquery then customers can use SQL
queries
programs written in spark and built-in
machine learning capabilities to analyze
the data
Albertsons a leading grocery retailer
uses Google data cloud and bigquery Omni
to analyze its supply chain and Order
management data from both Azure and
Google Cloud to improve inventory
planning
bigquery also supports key storage
formats for data lakes and lake houses
through big lake
Big Lake now supports Apache iceberg
with the popular Delta and Hoodie
formats coming very soon
users can now analyze and visualize all
this data using two styles of analysis
governed analysis
often used for official reporting and
embedded in applications
and self-service analysis which is more
distributed typically used for
departmental reporting and dashboards
Google has two popular tools used by 10
million users
each month for both these styles of
analysis looker
which is widely used for governed data
access
and data Studio
a leading self-service tool for
reporting dashboards and data
visualization
today we're announcing that by unifying
them with looker and looker Studio to
give self-service analysts access to
secure and govern data along with
Enterprise support and governance
capabilities
customers such as Wayfair are super
excited about this integration
looker also works with other popular
tools like tableau and today we're
announcing a preview of Luca support for
power bi
let's take a look at where bi can take
each and every one of you
Google products provide the information
you need when you need it
but why can't you get the same kind of
answers for your business
looker Google Cloud's business
intelligence solution is here to solve
that problem enabling you to go beyond
traditional dashboards and make your
organization's information accessible
and useful
bringing this Innovation to business
will be revolutionary just like
navigating a city after Google Maps
looker is Google for your business data
here's what we mean what if Google AI
were built into the tools you use to
store and analyze data at work
Google's vertex AI Vision takes data
like video images and audio and in real
time turns it into structured data ready
for business intelligence going beyond
the dashboard means using Google Glass
Enterprise to see insights and
recommendations based on your data in
real time
more access more transparency now that's
Google for your business
you know if a restaurant is busy before
you go or you can get rerouted or out of
traffic jam looker will help you connect
similar dots in a predictive way
a concert in five days will increase
foot traffic by 65 percent would you
like to adjust Staffing and inventory
yes looker and AI lets you respond to
changes in demand and turn insights into
action
foot traffic continues to be busy
encourage customers to visit an
alternate Shop with a reward card yes
smarter insights mean better experiences
and happy customers
to go beyond the dashboard and transform
the way you do business with looker
powered by Google Cloud
the data becomes even more powerful when
it's used in concert with AI and machine
learning
let me introduce Jun Yang Google's
clouds vice president of AI and Industry
solutions to tell you more about our
vision
[Music]
thank you Thomas
much of the data generated these days
are videos
in the past getting useful insights from
video streams in a secure and
cost-effective manner has been
challenging
today I'm excited to announce vertex AI
vision
a fully managed end-to-end application
development environment to help
developers build and deploy computer
vision application easily
let's use vertex AI vision for a smart
City use case
let's start by ingesting multiple video
streams from traffic cameras located at
busy intersection throughout the city
next we'll use a simple drag and drop
user interface we can choose from a
library of pre-built AI models let's go
ahead and select the occupancy analytics
model for our application
next
we will select bigquery to store the
streaming data and the model outputs
now we're ready to deploy the
application
we can use the model outputs to perform
time series forecasts with bigquery and
predict future traffic patterns
as you can see with vertex AI vision
developers can reduce the time required
to build and deploy computer vision
application from weeks to hours
an organization can create and run this
application at a fraction of the cost
stay on the topic of AI
Sunder just announced translation hub
our AI agent for self-serve document
translation that's built for Enterprises
AI agents Autobox solution that let
Everyday People apply AI to Common
business tasks
for example
contact center AI helps call center reps
serve customers better
similarly document AI helps accelerate
the interpretation and Analysis of
documents
zooming in on translation hub
as a public health official
I need to translate this document to 50
languages
normally I would have to send this to a
vendor wait for two weeks to get this
translation back
with translation Hub I can do it in
minutes
first I will import my document from
Google Drive into translation hub
next
I will select the template with my
preferences including 50 Target
languages in domain-specific AI model
that provides a higher quality
translation out of box
now I'm ready to translate
in seconds I get high quality
translation in all 50 languages while
preserving all layout colors graphics
and fonts
to refine the translation further I have
the option to use human in the loop
capability in Translation Hub and the
route the document to allow localization
expert for review
experts can now review and edit based on
this a prediction marker posted at a per
sentence level
when all the edits are done
translation Hub will rebuild the
documents now they're ready for
distribution
with translation Hub we can translate
content to 135 languages with four
layout retention and building human in
the loop content review capabilities
thanks to the power of AI document
translation can now be done quickly at
scale and cost effectively
back to you Thomas
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you June
our open data Cloud simplifies access to
data from software as a service
applications with sap we have created a
framework with predefined Integrations
bigquery data models and out of the box
reports
for ATB financials
month-end processes that used to take
five hours now run in just seconds
Rodan and Fields can now analyze
shopping behavior and forecast their
sales more accurately
further over 800
software partners are building the
products using our data cloud
and 17 of the most influential data
companies have joined us today in the
data Cloud Alliance to commit to Open
Standards and interoperability
today we're pleased to announce that
we've expanded our Partnerships with
mongodb elastic calibra palantir
servicenow and many more
we also have a new partnership with sisu
data
now let's talk about developers and
builders
today developers have more options than
ever before
but this array of choices has often led
to complexity
a loss of developer productivity and
have often exposed developers to
software vulnerabilities
to address these challenges at Google
Cloud
we have created opinionated golden paths
starting all the way from the IDE
through the build deploy an operations
process
to help developers create software
faster and more securely
today we're launching software delivery
Shield
which provides a fully managed
end-to-end software supply chain
security solution from source to
deployment
it has four important components first
is cloud workstations now in public
preview
instead of being just another Cloud
hosted IDE
Cloud workstations provides a secure
developer environment
especially for remote developers and
contractors who work with sensitive data
second with our assured open source
software service Google Now scans
analyzes and fusses over
250 of the most widely used Java and
python packages
providing you what secure software
libraries that you can depend on
third Cloud build our continuous
integration service now provides support
for salsa level 3 compliance by default
salsa is an emerging open standard to
ensure that the software you use or your
software supply chain is secure
fourth the new gke Security Management
dashboard
provides you with opinionated guidance
to improve the security posture of your
container workloads
in addition to helping you build more
securely
we're also announcing a number of
advances to help you build more
productively
with streamlined environments centered
around popular developer Stacks
including
flutter and Firebase
mongodb Atlas angular and node.js on
cloud run
and collaborative development using
replit
to simplify how you scale and operate
environments we continue to advance gke
autopilot
it enables developers to deploy and
scale containerized applications over
two and a half times faster than the
competition
customers like lows are already
benefiting their development team now
builds faster
fund One release every two weeks
to over 20 releases every day
the team at Allstate built an
application in just 90 days to show
customers how to more clearly and
securely protect their homes
to help developers learn faster
we were the very first cloud provider to
launch a learning subscription
today we're super excited to combine
those learning benefits with new perks
including Cloud credits
certification exam vouchers live
learning events
and even unique access to some of our
Superstar Google engineers and more now
let's talk about it people
who build the infrastructure for
transformation
Cloud infrastructure needs to change in
two fundamental ways
first customers increasingly want to use
cloud infrastructure for new types of
workloads
second with Moore's Law slowing new
infrastructure advances are required to
deliver performance improvements
we call this at Google
workload optimized infrastructure and
we're optimizing for seven key workloads
for AI optimized infrastructure we built
the tensor processing unit
TPU version 4 is now generally available
and runs large-scale training workloads
up to 80 faster and fifty percent
cheaper
LGA I researched used tpus to train an
AR model that has 300 billion parameters
outperforming other best-in-class
Computing infrastructure
to extend our AI infrastructure today we
are pleased to announce a deeper
strategic partnership with Nvidia
together we're committed to support AI
workloads using nvidia's latest
technology from gpus through to managed
services from Nvidia and AI models from
Google
Google and Nvidia are also partnering to
promote open source and collaborating on
open AI Frameworks including openxla Jax
and mon AI
for high performance Computing we're
announcing two new offerings in preview
for HBC compute new C3 instances
include the Intel Sapphire rapid
processor with 200 gigabits per second
networking the highest available in the
cloud
for high performance storage
we offer new hyper disk system
which delivers 80 percent higher iops
by decoupling compute instance sizing
from Storage performance
we're also partnering with HPC leaders
including Cadence and ansys to optimize
the performance and scale as well as to
simplify the deployment of their
software in our cloud
for media streaming we built media CDN
using a Global Network and our
experience with YouTube
media companies like Paramount plus are
able to deliver Flawless experiences
using media CDN
for customers in regulated markets and
countries with sovereignty laws we offer
sovereignty optimized workloads
as short workloads allow you to
configure
a regulatory compliant environment in
just minutes
and local controls are hosted with
Partners such as t-systems in Germany
and Palace and France
for more traditional workloads we're
announcing new capabilities
first with VMware engine Universal
integration
enabling you as a user to create and
migrate VMware workloads directly from
the VMware console
we're also announcing dual run a new
capability to re-host Mainframe
workloads in the cloud
the most new projects want Cloud first
optimized workloads to simplify
operations
we've automated managing and scaling
clusters with gke autopilot and anthos
multi-cluster management
to bring you edge Computing Google
distributed Cloud Edge
by anthos provides you a fully managed
Edge for low latency applications
it's being used to power
telecommunications networks at Bell and
Geo and it's modernizing retail stores
in many countries
we're also creating web 3 optimized
infrastructure
web 3 leaders like near nansen Solana
block demon Dapper labs and Sky Mavis
use Google Cloud so they can focus on
innovation
and today I'm excited to announce an
important new partnership with coinbase
let's welcome coinbase CEO Brian
Armstrong to share more
thanks Thomas we're excited to be
working with Google Cloud on this
partnership
coinbase has more than 100 million
verified users more than 14 000
institutional clients and we've spent
more than a decade Building
industry-leading Products on top of
blockchain Technology
we see our collaboration with Google as
an opportunity to bring web3 to a new
set of users and provide powerful
solutions to Founders and Developers
there are four key aspects to our
partnership
first coinbase will be using Google
Cloud to build Advanced Data and
analytics capabilities to better serve
our customers
Google Cloud bigquery will serve as the
centerpiece of this new data processing
architecture while vertex AI will enable
coinbase machine learning Engineers to
train and deploy models more rapidly and
at greater scale than ever before
combined this new platform will enable
coinbase to streamline and rapidly scale
its data processing and machine learning
capabilities without being hindered by
the complexity and cost of managing
underlying infrastructure
second coinbase Commerce enables
Merchants around the world to be able to
accept crypto payments through this
partnership we're looking forward to
enabling this for Google Cloud's
customers and partners so that they can
pay for cloud services with crypto
third developers will have access to
Google Cloud's blockchain data through
bigquery and this new offering will be
powered by coinbase Cloud's node service
the integration will allow developers to
instantly and reliably operate web3
based systems without the need for
expensive and complex infrastructure
and finally Google will use coinbase
prime for institutional crypto services
like secure custody and Reporting
we could not ask for a better partner to
execute our vision of building a trusted
Bridge into the web 3 ecosystem
I started coinbase with a desire to
create a more accessible Financial
system for everyone and Google's history
of supporting open source and
decentralized ecosystems made this a
natural fit
with this partnership with Google Cloud
we've now been able to power some of
that with coinbase cloud and so those
services will be exposed into Google
Cloud developers can go in there and
access the whole world of blockchain
data build web3 apps very quickly
without having to kind of manage and run
their own nodes for all the different
types of blockchains out there so I
imagine there's more and more things
that we can do over time I mean
basically we want to make Commerce on
the internet much more Global and fair
and free democratize and I think crypto
is kind of that native currency of the
internet so hopefully Google and
coinbase can kind of integrate more and
more things over time to power the
global internet economy
all right well thank you back to you
Thomas
thank you Brian Google is excited to
partner with you
in order to support all of these
workloads what can you invest and expand
our Global footprint
I'm excited to share that we're
announcing new Cloud regions in five
countries Austria Norway South Africa
Sweden and Greece
we now have 48 regions live or announced
now let's talk about security people
cyber security teams face a shortage of
skilled professionals and threats that
are growing every day in scale
sophistication and impact
it's our responsibility to protect your
privacy and Security in every product we
make so that every day you're safer with
Google
at Google Cloud we've engineered
security into our platform rather than
bolting it on
security operations are simplified
and shared responsibility evolves to
Shared faith
our commitment to you is twofold
first we keep you secure from cyber
attacks using the expertise we've
gleaned from securing our own business
our own technology infrastructure and
our billions of users
we simplify your security and compliance
without a short workload service
we deliver invisible zero trust security
with Beyond Corp
ensuring that access to services are
granted only to authenticate and
authorize users
we protect applications from abuse and
fraud with recapture
and we provide you with the world's
largest threat Observatory
with virus total
so in short you know what we at Google
Now
second to help you quickly and
effectively identify and resolve cyber
threats
we're excited to unveil
Chronicle security operations are Suite
that consolidates security analytics
security Automation and threat
intelligence
cyber security teams can now detect
investigate and respond to threats with
the speed scale and intelligence of
Google
take vertif a leading provider of
equipment and services for data centers
virtive uses Chronicle to ingest analyze
and retain all security telemetry vertif
now analyzes 22 times more security data
responds to three times more security
events and as a reduced investigation
Time by 50 percent with security queries
now taking just seconds
our next step is cyber security is to
bring mandate and its cyber Security
Experts and products to Google Cloud
please welcome Mandy and CEO Kevin
mandia to tell you more
[Music]
thank you very much thank you Thomas
Moore's Law may be slowing down but
threat actors in cyberspace are not
our mission at Mandan has always been to
secure companies and make them confident
in the Readiness as they operate their
businesses and to scale this Vision we
want to take our security expertise and
our threat intelligence and make it
software available to all companies and
this is something we've been focused on
for a long time
Manion is known for being I believe the
best and well to threat intelligence we
were designed to know more about threat
actors than anybody else on the planet
and we are now combining our security
expertise and our threat Intel with the
AI and compute speed and analytics of
Google so we can bring this Vision to
everyone and as a result
we can effectively automate the often
human intensive process of understanding
the threat actors find the needle in the
haystack and be able to do shields up
against these attacks and together we
can deliver on that shared mission of a
more secure world
now security teams always ask whenever
executive staff read the headlines hey
Will that attack work on us with Mandy
you can answer that question we have
hundreds of researchers around the globe
that speak over 30 languages that reside
in over 25 countries that research with
great rigor and discipline and catalog
the Fingerprints of all the intruders
one example of this is a group that we
call Finn 12. and fin 12 is a prolific
ransomware actor and during 2018 through
2020 they were targeting hospitals and
Health Care Facilities to make money and
conduct crime and we had the
Fingerprints of Finn 12. and in 2020 we
identified these ttps or tools tactics
and procedures and we were able to bring
them to our customers because they used
new and novel attacks that Circ they
circumvented conventional safeguards we
knew that our Intel would be critical
for our customers and we brought that
information to our customers so that
they could do shields up and defend
themselves
now having these early warning signs or
these indicators is critical for an
organization to operate confidently in
cyberspace and many times if fin 12 was
in your network you only had an hour or
so to do something about it before you
had a significant impactful breach so
with Google Cloud we're able to analyze
what's currently happening as well as
historical data in chronicle and use
machine learning and data analytics to
find that proverbial needle in the
haystack in this case fin 12 but we know
about the new novel and we learn more
every single day we can put the defenses
in without requiring you to do any
manual work at all
once we know how the attackers operate
and we're usually the first to know we
can help customers take the preventive
measures necessary to operate with
confidence one of those measures is
security validation where we take the
attacks we're aware of allow you to run
them in a safe and simple way to see how
you do against them and get unvarnished
truth whether it's secure or not another
thing we do with our threat intelligence
is we do attack surface management and
let you know where your vulnerabilities
are so you can do something about it now
I'm a big proponent of Google Cloud's
shared fate model by taking an active
stake in the security posture of all of
our customers we can help organizations
find and validate potential security
issues before they become an impactful
breach we're excited for the future
where mandian and Google Cloud can give
customers the latest threat intelligence
and cyber expertise
at compute speed delivered automatically
through SAS products and backed by the
leading managed services and consulting
services available
back to you Thomas
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you Kevin
we're combining the expertise of Google
and mandiant with many leading cyber
security Partners to further simplify
and enhance your security
to simplify multi-vendor security we
enable customers now to use the
preferred identity provider including
OCTA ping Forge rock or jump cloud
so there's no need to maintain
identities
in multiple places
we've launched a new Google cloud ready
sovereignty Solutions program with Palo
Alto networks Tallis Symantec and many
more partners
and all leading endpoint security
vendors including crowdstrike Microsoft
Defender for endpoint and cyber reason
have built Solutions with the Google
Cloud
we intend to keep expanding our open
security ecosystem with all endpoint and
other third-party Security Solutions to
keep you secure
now the success of any organization
hinges on unlocking the talent and
productivity of its people
with hybrid work the physical office is
no longer the sole space in which people
work together
this shift to hybrid
has been a once in a generation
disruption for millions of organizations
around the world
but Google workspace was built for this
very moment
workspace is the world's most popular
productivity tools with over 3 billion
users and more than 8 million paying
customers
organizations don't choose workspace to
Simply replace their existing tools
they choose to transform it the way in
which they work
I'm pleased now to invite aparna Papu
who leads Google workspace to share more
about the Direction with workspace
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you Thomas
those are phenomenal numbers but these
aren't just numbers to us they're real
people real organizations
and our mission is to meaningfully
connect people so that they can create
build and grow together
every time you use Gmail calendar docs
Drive chat Google me in your daily life
you are using workspace
today we need to think about the nature
of work a bit differently
to provide the right physical and
digital spaces
for every type of employee
for example
manufacturing or healthcare workers
typically need to be on site full-time
creatives on the other hand might decide
to come into the office for the
occasional ideation session but the rest
of the time they need a rich digital
workspace
this creates a gap in experience
to close that Gap and to help
organizations thrive in a hybrid World
we've invested heavily in smart canvas
our next Generation collaboration
experience and immersive connections our
approach to Bringing people together
through our communication products
with smart canvas a simple ad mention
pulls in the right people Data Insights
in a workflow directly in the places
where you're already working
and now smart canvas is extensible to
third-party applications like Salesforce
zendesk figma and many more
immersive connections collapses the
boundary between people locations and
devices
making every interaction feel as if
you're actually together
features in our Google meet product like
automatic light adjustments so wherever
you're working you look your best noise
cancellation mobile companion is a
second screen make it easier for people
to be seen and heard whether you're in
the office or at home
and now we're taking a step further with
immersive connections with speaker
Spotlight in Google Slides
collapsing the boundary between the
story
and the Storyteller
all of this built on a secure private
and compliant platform
we're extending our confidentiality
with client-side encryption now in Gmail
and Google Calendar
and our support for global data loss
prevention in real time in Google Chat
stepping back let's look at the digital
workspace of the future
do we really think that people are going
to be searching for Content importing
images fussing with fonts and wrestling
with templates in a manual way
here at Google we we envision a whole
new era of communication expression and
co-creation all powered by incredible
advancements in artificial intelligence
an era in which storytelling is richer
more expressive and frankly more fun
what generative AI unleashes people's
creativity and unlocks new workflows
let's look at an example of how we might
see this come to life here in workspace
Amanda is a marketer at a running shoe
company footwear company
and she's been tasked with creating a
video to introduce their brand new zero
carbon high performance running shoe
to get started she collects relevant
data and assets
then she might type something like this
create a 90 second video
foreign campaign with using our brand
guidelines of people running
make it outdoorsy and maybe add some
upbeat music
with the power of Google AI workspace
takes all of this in and suggests
several different creative directions
for her to choose from
she likes the look of the mountain
concept and that's the one she picks
she begins to refine the idea with the
help of intelligent suggestions and
iterations she makes a few changes until
she finally lands on something she loves
when Amanda's ready she sends it to her
team for review and collaboration
of course the team has some ideas
Google AI suggests applying some of
their feedback
and Amanda accepts those suggestions and
actions it directly in Google Chat
just like that she has a killer launch
video
this is just one scenario in our mission
to help people connect create build and
grow together back to you Thomas
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you aparna
when it comes to climate change people
governments and corporations are more
motivated than ever before
but they need access to the right
information to measure and improve upon
their ESG commitments
Google's search interest for how to
reduce my common footprint has risen by
460 percent over the past 10 years
today Google cloud is making it easier
for our customers to make better
sustainability decisions every single
day
I'm pleased to announce that Google
Cloud carbon footprint is now generally
available
and free for every user in the cloud
console
so that you can see and optimize your
carbon impact
our customers Shopify
uses detailed emissions data to drive
their mission to be the lowest carbon
Commerce platform
earlier this year we announced the
general availability of Earth engine on
Google Cloud for better climate risk
prediction and resilience
for Natural Resources Canada
Earth engine on Google Cloud
helps map the tree canopy and support
models for permafrost crop status and
Water Resources
with this data provinces can monitor
their land status and identify how to
rehabilitate and transform these sites
Google Maps recently expanded our
eco-friendly routing features to 40 new
countries in Europe
I'm pleased to share that eco-friendly
routing is coming soon to Google Maps
platform on Google Cloud
for developers and the transportation
industry ride sharing and delivery
companies for instance can embed
eco-friendly routes into their driver
apps
to provide customers with sustainability
data sets and solutions we have over 20
partners with the Google cloud ready
sustainability designation
and a new partnership with dun and Brad
street and climate engine
now as we wrap this Keynote
I want to share my appreciation for all
of the people
who are building and transforming their
business with Google Cloud
on behalf of our teams we're excited to
develop technology with the EU today
to help each of you
create a more amazing and a better
tomorrow
thank you so very much and enjoy the
rest of Google Cloud next
[Applause]
[Music]